learn how to get chat GPT and other llms
to give you the perfect responses by
mastering prompt engineering strategies
Anya Kubo is one of our most popular
instructors and in this course she will
teach you the latest techniques to
maximize your productivity with large
language models hi everyone and welcome
to this course on prompt engineering my
name is Anya Kubo and I'm a software
developer as well as course Cruiser here
on free co-camp as well as on my own
channel this is going to be a unique
course for me as there is going to be a
lot less coding going on but a lot more
understanding about the topic of prompt
engineering and why some companies are
paying up to 335 000 US dollars a year
according to Bloomberg for people in
this profession and no no coding
background is necessarily required so
what are we waiting for let's do it in
this course we will learn what prompt
engineering is exactly get a brief
introduction to AI a look at large
language models or llms such as chat GPT
a look at text image models such as mid
journey I look at emerging models this
would include text-to-speech text audio
or speech to text as well as prompt
engineering mindset best practices zero
shot prompting few shop prompting Chain
of Thought AI hallucinations vexes text
embeddings and also end with a quick
intro to chat GPT so let's start off
with looking at what exactly prompt
engineering is in the first place
prompt Engineering in a nutshell is a
career that came about of the back of
the rise of artificial intelligence it
involves human writing refining and
optimizing prompts in a structured way
this is done with the intention of
perfecting the interaction between
humans and AI to the highest degree
possible
not only that however a prompt engineer
is then also required to continuously
monitor those prompts ensure their
effectiveness with time as AI progresses
maintaining an up-to-date prompt Library
will be a requirement that is placed
onto the prompt engineer as well as
reporting on findings and in general
being a thought leader in this space but
why do we need it and how did it come
about from AI before moving on let's
actually make sure we are on the same
page about what exactly AI is artificial
intelligence is the simulation of human
intelligence processes by machines I say
simulation as artificial intelligence is
not sentient at least not yet anyways
meaning it cannot think for itself as
much as it may seem it does often and
this is certainly the case with tools
such as chat GPT for example when we say
AI we are simply referring to a term
called machine learning machine learning
works by using large amounts of training
data that is then analyzed for
correlations and patterns these patterns
are then used to predict outcomes based
on the training data provided so for
example here we are feeding data saying
that if a paragraph looks like this with
this type of title then it should be
categorized as international finance the
second paragraph should be put in the
category of adding reports and so on
with some code we should be able to
train our AI model to correctly guess
what future paragraphs are about and
that's it of course that is a super
basic example and we would need way more
data than these five paragraphs right
here but you get the idea if you want to
build your own AI model and understand
the concept of machine learning better
as a total beginner please check out my
video on it on my channel code with Anya
Kubo as of now rapidly improving
generative AI techniques can create
realistic text responses and even images
music and other media thanks to the huge
amounts of training data and talented
developers working on it today
why is prompt engineering useful
with the quick and exponential growing
rise of AI even The Architects of it
themselves struggle to control it and
its outputs this might be a bit hard to
understand but think of it this way if
you were to ask an AI chat bot what is
four plus four you would expect it to
say eight right the result of 8 is
pretty indisputable however imagine you
are a young student trying to learn the
English language I'm gonna show you just
how different responses can be based on
the prompts you feed and in turn your
learning experience
for this example I'm going to be using
chat gpt's gpt4 model so let's start
with the basics if you were to type
correct my paragraph and then paste it a
badly written paragraph so just like
this today was great in the world for me
I went to Disneyland with my mom it
could have been better though if it
wasn't raining great the young English
learner has a better sentence but it
kind of stops there and the Lana is just
left to their own devices and honestly
the sentence really isn't that great
anyway
what if the learner could get the best
sentences possible from a teacher who
understands their interests to keep them
engaged with the correct prompts we can
actually create that with AI
so let's give it a go and let's write a
prompt to do this so here is the prompt
I'm gonna give it I'm going to write I
want you to act as a spoken English
teacher I will speak to you in English
and you'll reply to me in English to
practice my spoken English I want you to
keep my reply neat limiting the reply to
100 words I also want you to strictly
correct my grammar mistakes and typos
and I want you to ask me a question in
your reply now let's start practicing
you could ask me a question first
remember I want you to strictly correct
my grammar mistakes and typos
so that's my prompt you can also go a
step further and ask it to correct your
factual errors too which I think would
be an excellent addition to the prompt
that will benefit the young learner okay
so let's go ahead and add that to the
prompt okay and let us do its thing and
great so now this is way more
interactive as you'll see it's asking
you a question and telling you what to
do and will provide you with corrections
if needed so in a way you're
communicating with the AI it's giving
you suggestions and you're learning
along the way it's a completely
different experience thanks to the
prompt that we wrote pretty cool right
we're going to be diving into a bunch of
these Concepts soon but first let's
start with the basics
linguistics Linguistics is the study of
language it focuses on everything from
phonetics so the study of how speech
sounds are produced and perceived
phonology so the study of sound patterns
and changes morphology the study of word
structure syntax so the study of
sentence structure semantics so the
study of linguistic meaning pragmatics
so in other words the study of how
language is used in context historical
Linguistics or the study of language
change
sociolinguistics or in other words the
study of the relation between language
and Society
computational Linguistics so the study
of how computers can process human
language and physiolinguistics or the
study of how humans acquire and use
language so a lot Linguistics are the
key to prompt engineering why
understanding the nuances of language
and how it is used in different contexts
is crucial for crafting effective
prompts not only that but knowing how to
use a grammar or language structure that
is universally used will result in the
AI system returning back the most
accurate results
as you can imagine the sheer amount of
data that is trained on is most likely
to mostly use the standard grammar and
language structure that is universally
used so sticking to the standardization
is key
language models
imagine a world where computers possess
the power to understand and generate
human language a world where machines
can chat write stories and even compose
poetry
in this magical realm language models
can come into play
they are like the Wizards of the digital
realm capable of understanding and
creating human-like text
a language model is a clever computer
program that learns from a vast
collection of written text it takes in
books articles websites and all sorts of
written resources allowing it to gather
knowledge about how humans use language
just like a master linguist it becomes
an expert in the art of conversation
grammar and style
but how does this all work well imagine
you feed a sentence the language model
will then analyze the sentence examine
the order of words their meanings and
the way they fit together then the
language model would generate a
prediction or a continuation of the
sentence that makes sense based on its
understanding of the language it will
weave words together one by one creating
a response that seems like it was
crafted by a human being imagine having
a conversation with a language model as
if you're exchanging ideas with a
digital friend you ask a question and it
responds with a well-crafted answer you
tell a joke and it counters with a witty
remark it's like having a language
expert by your side always ready to
assist and engage in conversation now
you may wonder where these language
models are used they can be found in
various places from your smartphone's
virtual assistants to customer service
chat Bots and even in the creative realm
of writing they help us find information
offer suggestions and create content but
remember while language models possess
incredible abilities they still rely on
the humans who create and train them
they are in fact a fusion of human
Ingenuity and the power of algorithms
blending the best of both worlds let's
start off by looking at the history of
language models starting with the first
AI Elisa back in the 60s
Eliza is an early natural language
process in computer program created from
1964 to 1966 at MIT by Joseph wiesenbaum
Eliza was designed to simulate a
conversation with a human being Eliza
had a special note for mimicking a
rigerian psychotherapist someone who
essentially listens attentively and asks
probing questions to help people explore
their thoughts and feelings Eliza's
secret weapon was its Mastery of pattern
matching it had a treasure Trove of
predefined patterns each associated with
specific responses these patterns were
like magical spells allowed Eliza to
understand and respond to human language
when you engage in a conversation with
Eliza it would carefully analyze your
input seeking patterns and keywords and
without transform your words into a
series of symbols searching for patterns
that match those symbols in its
repertoire once a pattern was detected
Eliza would work its magic by
transforming your words into a question
or statement that aim to explore your
thoughts and emotions it was as if Eliza
was holding up a metaphorical mirror
encouraging you to delve deeper into
your own thinking for example if you
said something like I feel sad Eliza
would detect the pattern and respond
with a question like why do you think
you feel sad it encouraged reflection
and introspection just like a caring
therapist would
but here's the delightful twist Eliza
didn't truly understand what you were
saying it was just a clever illusion it
used pattern matching and some creative
programming tricks to create the
illusion of understanding while in
reality it was just following a set of
predefined rules
yet even though Eliza was a simple
program people were often captivated by
its conversational abilities
they felt heard and understood even if
they knew they were talking to a machine
it was like having a digital confident
who was always ready to listen and offer
gentle guidance
Eliza's Creator weisenbaum intended the
program as a method to explore
communication between humans and
machines he was surprised and shocked
that individuals including his secretary
attributed human-like feelings to the
computer program but that is a whole
other topic of conversation in itself
Eliza's impact was profound sparking
interest and research in the field of
natural language processing it paved the
way for more advanced systems that could
truly understand and generate human
language it was the humble beginning of
a grand Adventure in the world of
conversational AI
fast forward to the 1970s when a program
named shudlu appeared it could
understand simple commands and direct
with a virtual world of blocks although
shirt Liu wasn't a language model per se
a lady foundation for the idea of
machines comprehending human language
but the true language models began
around 2010 when the power of deep
learning and neural networks came into
Play Enter The Mighty GPT short for
generative pre-trained Transformer ready
to conquer the world of language in the
year 2018 the first iteration of GPT
emerge created by the company open AI it
was trained on a large amount of text
Data absorbing Knowledge from books
articles and a large chunk of the
Internet gpt-1 Was A Taste of things to
come an impressive language model but
small compared to its descendants that
we used today as time went on the Saga
continued with the arrival of gpt2 in
2019 in followed by gpt3 in 2020 this
was a Titan among language models a
quilt with a large number of parameters
over 175 billion to be precise GPT 3
dazzled the world with its unparalleled
ability to understand respond and even
generate creative pieces of writing the
arrival of gpt3 marked a real turning
point in terms of language models and AI
at the time of writing we now also have
gpt4 trained on pretty much the whole
internet rather than outdated large data
sets as well as Bart from Google and so
much more
it would seem we only just at the start
when it comes to language models and AI
so learning how to harness this data
with prompt engineering is a smart move
for anyone today
The Prompt engineering mindset when
thinking of a good prompts it is always
best to get in the correct mindset
essentially you want to just write one
prompt right and not have to waste time
and tokens writing lots of different
prompts until you get the result you
desire so essentially kind of the same
as when you Google stuff right how good
are your Googling skills now as opposed
to five years ago I'm assuming a lot
better we have grown to intuitively know
what to type into Google the first time
round as to not waste time having the
same mindset for prompt engineering can
also be applied the hail Eric of the
infinite machine learning podcast says
it well when he says I personally like
the analogy of prompting to designing
effective Google searches there are
clearly better and worse ways to write
queries against the Google search engine
that solve your task this variance
exists because of the opaqueness of what
Google is doing under the hood
we are going to keep this in mind for
the remainder of the course
a quick intro to using chat GPT by open
AI
so as I said in this course for the
examples I will be using chat gbt's gpt4
model in order to follow along or just
to understand how we are going to be
using the platform please head over to
openai.com and just go ahead and sign up
I've already signed up so I'm just going
to go ahead and log in and that will
take me to the platform in which I can
choose what I want to interact with
for this tutorial we are going to be
interacting with chat gpt4 so please go
ahead and click on here and that will
take you to the platform and then I'm
just gonna go ahead and switch to the
gpt4 model which is the latest one okay
so great you will see here was the
previous chance that I've had I'm just
going to minimize this and if we want to
create a new chat all we'd have to do is
click the new chat button okay so here
for example what I can do is just go
ahead and ask any questions so what is
four plus four and then hit send and
that will essentially give me a response
so I'm now interacting with chat gpg4
on this occasion I can actually build on
the previous conversation so what I can
do is say great now can you add another
5 to that
what is the answer and it will take into
account everything that I have
previously okay I am building on top of
the knowledge that it already has
great so again this is just a very quick
introduction to how to use this we will
be doing a deeper dive into this
throughout this course
so once again to create a new chat all
you'd have to do is create your chat and
if you want to delete the old one just
go ahead and click that delete button
and that will delete it and then a new
chat is brought up automatically
wonderful
now you might have seen my course on
open AI in which we can also use the API
and to use the API just go over to the
API references and all you would have to
do is get an API key and the API key can
be viewed here
and then you just go ahead and create an
API key and that will allow you to
interact with the open AI API in order
for you to build out your own platforms
just as the one we saw before so if
you're interested in that please do head
over to my tutorial on this again on the
free curcum Channel otherwise let's
continue using chat GPT so once again
I'm just going to log in and head back
to the platform here and that is it we
are ready to go
another thing I want to discuss is
tokens as you might find that you have
run out of the free tokens that you have
in order to interact with chat gbt so in
order to do that I'm just going to show
you this I'm going to head over to the
documentation and talk to you a little
bit about tokens
so GPT 4 essentially processes all text
in chunks called tokens and this token
is approximately four characters or 0.75
word for English text
and we essentially get charged by token
if you want to know exactly how many
tokens you are using you can check it
out here you can check out the tokenizer
tool and it will give you a rough
example so for example I can say
what is four plus four and with that
piece of text the total count of tokens
is going to be six okay so there we go
that is exactly how many tokens will be
used in order to produce a answer for
this request
great so here is the URL for that you
can play around with it I hope you have
fun if you want to see your usage you
can head over to your account and then
you can manage your account and this
should be able to show you your usage so
it will show you your usage right here
per month and then you can of course
also add billing in order to carry on
using chat GPT in case you've used up
all your tokens and you can't use it
anymore so once again this is under
account billing overview so just go
check it out okay and now back to the
platform
best practices
the biggest misconception when it comes
to prompt engineering is that it's an
easy job with no science to it I imagine
a lot of people think it's just about
constructing a one-off sentence such as
correct my paragraph that we saw in the
previous example when you start to look
at it creating effective prompts relies
on a bunch of different factors here are
some things to consider when writing a
good prompt
consider writing clear instructions with
details in your query consider adopting
a Persona as well as specifying the
format using iterative prompting meaning
if you have a multi-pot question or if
the First Response wasn't sufficient you
could continue by asking follow-up
questions or asking the model to
elaborate and avoid leading the answer
try not to make your prompts so leading
that it inadvertently tells the model
what answer you're expecting this might
bias the response on Julie and finally
limit the scope for long topics if
you're asking about a broad topic it's
helpful to break it down or limit the
scope to get a more focused answer let's
look at some of these now in order to
write clearer instructions we can adopt
writing more details in our queries and
to get the best results don't assume the
AR knows what you are talking about
writing something like when is the
election implies that you are expecting
the ER to know so what election you are
talking about and what country you mean
this may result in you asking a few
follow-up questions to finally get the
result you want resulting in time loss
and frankly perhaps some frustration
consider taking the time to write a
prompt with clear instructions so for
example instead of writing when is the
election you could write when is the
next presidential election for Poland
so let's go ahead and run this and this
will be much more precise and knows
exactly what we are asking about it's
not going to go guessing and waste our
time as well as waste our resources so
in other words tokens that we are using
so in other words money in order to get
the right answer the first time here are
some other examples of how you could
write clearer prompts
so for example we have this prompt here
which says write code to filter out the
ages from data and if you run it you
don't really know what language it's
going to come back with let's see so for
example here is using python I actually
didn't want to use Python okay so now
we've lost some tokens asking this we've
also lost some time and we just haven't
got the right response this could have
been so easily avoided so I'm gonna stop
this from generating and let's try again
so this time let's be more specific by
writing write a JavaScript function that
will take an array of objects and filter
out the value of age property and put
them in a new array please explain what
each code snippet does
in this example I am not assuming the AI
knows what computer language I like to
use and I am being more specific about
what my data actually looks like on this
occasion it's an array of objects not
only that I am also asking the AI to
explain why it's doing each step so the
I in turn can understand and not just
copy paste the code without gaining any
knowledge from it okay so here you can
see a live example what's coming back to
us from gpt4 it's given us the correct
code so I have checked that and I was
also giving us an example of how you
would use the function which is
something I didn't ask which is super
useful it's kind of gone above and
beyond for helping me out in
understanding what is going on
let's look at another example we can
write tell me what this essay is about
so I'm going to just type this and then
just paste in an essay and hit go and
then chat gbt will do its thing it's
going to give me a summarization as it
thinks best so on this occasion it is
essentially giving me numbered points
about what this essay is about they're
really long I really didn't want to read
this much it's pretty much looking to be
the same as the original essay so this
is not something I wanted I should have
been way more specific in telling it
what I need
so what I'm going to do is just add to
this conversation so it's going to learn
on what I wrote previously and I'm just
going to specify to use bullet points to
explain what this essay is about making
sure each point is no longer the 10
words long so I am being super specific
in providing the instructions of what I
want and let's hit go so now this is a
lot shorter okay as you can see each
point is no longer than 10 words long
and then I'm going to get a summary that
is a bit longer and will give me a
summary of the essay that I pasted in
above
so great of course you can do this on
any essay or piece of text that you wish
and you can set your own clear and
Specific Instructions as well
okay so I hope you can see why the
second one is better it's because I am
not assuming the AI knows what kind of
format I want the summarization of the
essay to be in I am being specific that
I want very short notes on the essay in
bullet point format with a short
conclusion at the end if I did not put
this the summary could have been just as
long as the essay itself and the prompt
could be considered useless in my eyes
next up we can also adopt a persona when
writing prompts it is sometimes helpful
to create a Persona this means you are
asking the AI to respond to you in a
certain character so exactly like the
English language teacher example we saw
earlier using a Persona in prompt
engineering can help ensure that the
language model's output is relevant
useful and consistent with the needs and
preferences of the target audience
making it a powerful tool for developing
effective language models that meet the
needs of users let's look at some
examples of adopting a Persona so for
example you can have this prompt right
here write a program for a sister's High
School graduation that will be read out
to a family and close friends
so let's go ahead and run this and let's
see what comes back
so there we go it is quite good in a
room for working enclosed tires we
gathered to honor the Mist in our eyes
for a journey has ended another begun as
our dear sister steps into the sun
okay so it's coming out with a poem I
can see here it is quite a good one I
guess probably better than anything that
I would have written and it is maybe a
little bit generic maybe that's what you
wanted I think we can do better than
this so let's try this
this time I'm going to write a prompt
with a Persona so this time I'm going to
specify who I'm writing as I'm gonna do
write a poem as Helena
Helena is 25 years old
and an amazing writer
her writing style is similar to famous
21st century
poet rupee
cower writing as Helena write a poem for
her 18 year old
sister
to celebrate
her sister's High School graduation
this will be read out to
friends and family
at the Gathering
okay so let's check it out now we're
writing as Helena she's 25 she's an
amazing writer and we've also assigned a
writing style so let's check it out
now chat GPT should be using anything it
knows about rupee kawer hopefully from
the internet in order to apply that
style to this poem okay and as you can
see this is maybe a little bit more
affectionate we've said sister it's
obviously a younger sister so the words
little sister are being used and in
general I think this is a much higher
quality poem and if Helena truly does
have the style of rupee kawu in writing
it will be almost indistinguishable who
wrote this poem chat and GPT or Helena
so here we go here's the fourth thing it
starts off in the garden of our youth I
watch you bloom from Bud to Blossom from
child to woman 18 Summers passed again
utilizing the fact that we fed it she
was 18 and every Winter's chill only
made you stronger a force of nature
still so yes in my eyes this poem is a
lot more better it's much more refined
it's much more personal thanks to the
prompts that we wrote we've already had
a brief look at specifying format when
we limited the word count of our bullet
points in a previous example so that was
a great example limiting words is one
that I use often however we can do a
bunch of other things including
specifying if something is a summary a
list or a detailed explanation heck you
can even create checklists so I'm gonna
go ahead and show you how to do this
here is an example prompt and I'm just
going to run it and there we go we have
created a checklist so many things you
can do in chat GPT
just measure to specify the type of
format you want and it should be able to
do it
okay great now that we looked at some
best practices let's move on to some
more advanced topics in the prompt
engineering
in this section I'm going to talk about
two types of prompting we can do zero
shot prompting and few shot prompting
zero shot prompting leverages the
pre-trained model's understanding of
words and concept relationships without
further training and few shot prompting
enhances the model with training
examples via the prompt avoiding
retraining so essentially in the context
of the gpt4 model we don't really need
to do much we are already using all of
the data that it has in order to ask
when is Christmas in America so let's go
ahead and do some zero shot prompting
when is Christmas
in America and here go okay so it
clearly already has the data for this we
don't need to add any examples or
anything like that
so as you can see Zero shot prompting
refers to a way of querying models like
GPT without any explicit training
examples for the task at hand
in the context of machine learning and
not just GPT zero shot typically means
that a model performs a task without
having seen any examples of that task
during its training
okay great so now let's look at few shop
prompting so once again with zero shot
prompting we gave our language model a
prompt and got a response but sometimes
that's just not enough and we need a bit
more training so let's use few shop
prompting and level up our language
model by showing a few examples of the
tasks we wanted to perform
so instead of zero examples we give it a
tiny bit of data
so let's think what would gpd4 not know
I guess it would not know my favorite
types of food so for example let's check
what is ania's favorite
type of food
plural
okay and I mean it can guess but no it's
just telling me that it doesn't know so
that is absolutely fine let's stop
generating so now let's feed it in some
example data I'm going to feed it in a
tiny bit of data
ania's favorite
type of food
include sorry about my English
let's go with burgers
fries I love fries pizza and here enter
okay so we are essentially giving chat
GPT some information
uh so now if I type
what
restaurant should I take Anya
two in Dubai this
weekend and hit here it should hopefully
understand that my favorite types of
foods are burgers fries and pizza and
given that find me some restaurants in
Dubai that I would like to go to so here
are some this has been updated as of
September 2021 but you know these are
pretty good ones so I would totally go
to these this is a great example of
fuchsia prompting in which it wouldn't
have been able to answer this question
if I hadn't had given it some example
data or just trained the model a little
bit more in order to get the response
that I want
great
AI hallucinations now we're delving into
something you probably never thought
you'd hear in an AI context and that's
hallucinations
so what exactly are AI hallucinations
and no they're not when your AI
assistance starts seeing unicorns and
rainbows it's actually a time that
refers to the unusual outputs that AI
models can produce when they
misinterpret data
a prime example of this is Google's deep
dream you know that project that turns
pictures of your dog into a nightmarish
blend of dog faces and well more dog
faces deep dream is an experiment that
visualizes the patterns learned by a
neural network it is built to over
interpret and enhance the patterns it
sees in an image or in other words fill
in the gaps with images
but some of the time those gaps can be
filled with the wrong thing this is an
example of an unusual output that AI
models can produce when they
misinterpret data
now why do these hallucinations happen
you ask they're trained on a huge amount
of data and they make sense of new data
based on what they've seen before
sometimes however they make connections
that are let's call it creative and
voila an AI hallucination occurs despite
their funny results AI hallucinations
aren't just entertaining they're also
quite enlightening they show us how our
AI models interpret and understand data
it's like a sneak peek into their
thought processes
this example is actually an AI image
hallucination as I thought it would be a
fun one to show AI hallucinations can
also happen with text models an example
of This Is Us asking a text model about
a historical figure and the text model
not having an answer and hallucinating
one instead resulting in an inaccurate
response
vectors and text embeddings to finish
off I'm going to leave you with a
slightly more complex subject we are
going to take a quick look at the topic
of text embedding and vectors
in computer science particularly in the
realm of machine learning and natural
language processing or NLP text
embedding is a popular technique to
represent textual information in a
format that can be easily processed by
algorithms especially deep learning
models in the context of prompt
engineering llama embedding refers to
representing prompts in a form that the
model can understand and process this
involves converting the text prompt into
a high dimensional Vector that captures
its semantic information
so essentially the word food is
represented by this if using the create
embedding API from openai okay so you
will see it's represented the word was
represented by an array of lots and lots
of numbers but why do this well think
about it this way if you ask a computer
to come back with a similar word to food
you wouldn't really expect it to come
back with burger or pizza right that's
what a human might do and thinking of
similar words to food a computer would
more likely look at the word
lexicographically kind of like when you
scroll through a dictionary and come
back with foot for example this is kind
of useless to us we want to capture a
word's semantic meaning so the meaning
behind the word text embeddings do
essentially that thanks to the data
captured in this super long array
now I can find words that are similar to
food in a large Corpus of text by
comparing text embedding to text
embedding and returning the most similar
ones so words such as Burger instead of
foot will be more similar
to create a text embedding of a word or
even a whole sentence check out the
create embedding API here from open AI
so here is the URL that you should visit
and to create your own text of betting
you're going to have to create a post
request to this endpoint okay so that's
what you can do you can also take the
code from here so this is an example
request written in node.js and you would
have to install the open AI package take
these two methods from it in order to
pass through your open AI API key that I
showed you how to get earlier as a
refresher you should go here and view
API keys to create your own API key
and once you pass that through you can
then use the cons configuration and pass
it through here in order to use open Ai
and all of its wonderfulness including
the create embedding method in which you
pass through an object that object has
to include the model and it also is
going to include the input so in this
case it is the text that you want to
turn into and embedding so this is the
code for doing that and here is the
response which comes back as an object
and then you would use dot notation to
get the data go into the array in order
to get the embedding so this is going to
be the embedding that we saw earlier
it's an array made up of numbers and a
lot of these numbers okay so not just
these three these this does spill out
and this will be a very very long array
of numbers that will give you this
semantic meaning of whatever text you
pass through
okay so please have a go at playing
around with this API in order to create
your own text embeddings and compare
them against other text embeddings in
order to find similar text and that's it
thank you so much for watching this
course on prompt Engineering in which we
covered what it is we covered an
introduction to AI as well as looked at
Linguistics language models prompt
engineering mindset using gpg4 had a
look at Best Practices as well as zero
shot and few shot prompting as well as
AI hallucinations vectors or text
embeddings and this recap right here so
I hope you've enjoyed it and I'll see
you again on the free cocam Channel